[Music]
let's go to sean in salt lake city to
the utes what's up sean
hey how you doing dr john i'm good
brother what's up dude how can i help
good well hopefully this will be an easy
answer for you but um
those are never there's never easy
answers go for it well we'll try to give
you a softball um
so i grew up in the uh very devout
mormon family here in utah and uh
it really controlled everything i did
any decisions i made that kind of stuff
it just like we went along with the
church and uh
recently you know i've some of my
beliefs have changed and that kind of
stuff and
i don't know if you call it a faith
crisis or what but
i'm just trying to get some guidance on
how to maneuver through that
quote-unquote faith crisis
spin out and get in a bad spot yeah
number one thanks for your bravery
brother and um
spinning out's part of the process
unfortunately for the people who
actually pay attention and are committed
to any sort of faith walk if you don't
have a crisis at some point i don't
think you're really digging in because
this stuff's hard
um
how uh
how old are you
i'm 35 35 okay so what brought about
this is it you've been reading you've
been listening you just kind of been
rolling your eyes you got kids all of a
sudden like what what what's leading to
this
yeah so i mean i've got three kids that
are eight six and three and um
you know just kind of teaching them
things that that i learned growing up
and then
and then yeah just been reading some
stuff and
um
the history of the church and things
like that that didn't fit right with me
and i felt like
that wasn't
taught to me correctly when i was a kid
so in a way i kind of felt betrayed
and
that's kind of where it just
started so you know i've been trying to
you know teach my kids values and morals
and that kind of stuff because and that
doesn't change i think that's
that's what you should do as a father
right um yeah yes yes values and morals
are good
it's fathering 101 yes
yeah
so that's that's where it really came
from as i just you know started
learning more and digging deeper into
things and it just
kind of shook me weird and yeah are you
married that's a challenge i am yeah
how is your wife
what's your thoughts on this
um she's right where i am you know she
didn't have the same upbringing that i
did um
her parents
didn't really raise her in the church
which is cool but um
but yeah she's she's very supportive and
she'll walk right alongside me i just
i want to make sure that i'm
strong and you know gonna leave my
family correctly and not just
like i said earlier spin out and
okay not handle it right so do you have
what are you scared of
uh have you said like what are you
scared of doing
i mean
are you
are you done with the church
i feel like i am but yeah like i'm kind
of i'm scared to even say that because
you know in in this area it just
dominates so much of our social life and
our culture yep yep and and i'm afraid
that you're going to lose everything i
mean you're going to lose your community
your friend community probably your
parents i mean you're gonna lose a lot
right
yeah yeah and that's what i'm scared of
and i don't want
that so you're not getting you're not
scared of getting struck by lightning or
like burning in hell or whatever i don't
know what the end result of your faith
is but you're you're more concerned
about like you love these people and you
still want to go to dinner you still
have christmas parties and stuff yeah
yeah like i mean i still want to be
around and be involved in everything and
all that i just don't
maybe i'm scared of what people think of
me and you know that kind of stuff and
have you
have you sat down with any of your close
friends and let them know where you're
at
yeah yeah i have how'd that go
it was good it was good they're really
supportive about it and um
you know some of them even agreed and
kind of going through the same thing
that i am yeah so i mean it's good we're
kind of it's
it's a smaller community that's for sure
yeah a smaller community of people who
are asking questions or who are thinking
through things or who want to do life a
little bit differently
yeah okay
um
so i've been where you are thinking
through like uh man where i'm at where
i'm learning and where i'm growing is
different than how i grew up so let's
take let's take religion off the table
because that's that can feel jarring
let's put parenting on the table
which is also jarring but here we are
um
i don't know anybody
that's not true maybe a couple maybe a
couple who want to reproduce exactly
verbatim
the parenting that they received when
they're considering how they're going to
parent their kids
almost everyone i know has some sort of
there was some really great stuff there
was some
some neutral stuff and there's some
stuff i'm absolutely gonna do
differently with my kids
now do we actually end up doing that we
all talk about you know i hear my dad's
voice coming out of my mouth and i'm
like what is that like one time i even
looked behind me because it sounded like
him
and
anyway so
we have that and so the the
mark of maturity the mark of growing up
the mark of wisdom is
can i hold in one hand
the things about my parents the way they
raised me that i didn't like that i'm
gonna do differently and
can i still hold the good parts and the
parts that respect them the parts that
love them deeply
and if you can do both
that's wisdom can you hold both sides
and and go forward
right that's wisdom
most cannot
most have to burn down the other things
so they can before they feel like they
can cross a bridge
and i think that's what's wrong with the
world right now
i can't possibly talk about climate
science without having to
also back everything on this side of the
political aisle or i can't possibly talk
about economics without having to and
and capitalism without having to you
know what i mean imagine showing up to
get your deer process pulling out of a
prius i thought the poor guy was gonna i
thought his head was gonna explode right
yeah we're that's the world we're in
right now and so what i want people to
do is to begin to to understand there's
a both hand to it
here's what that is you whether you want
to admit it or not and i think you did
just admit it so i'm not going to put
words in your mouth there you got some
good stuff growing up in the church
absolutely you got some good values you
got some a weekly connection you got a
tribe you got a crew you got a you got
some good stuff
and
over time you've the the the buzz word
now is deconstruction you're beginning
to walk your faith back and go
it was built on something i didn't
realize that was built on and most of us
think well if the foundation's wonky if
the if the story here is wonky then the
whole things won't and that's where i'm
gonna say
the journey that you're on is both and
can i re-imagine re-read re-walk through
rethink re-whatever this foundation part
the story part the
did that thing really happen like that
because it sounds bonkers
and not throw the whole thing away
and what i'll tell you is
i spent a season
years as just a functioning atheist i
mean the whole thing was just ridiculous
and then over time and i and i actually
came around it backwards i started doing
crisis work and meeting with people who
were dead in the middle of the night and
they're loved and i found it in a much
more truthful visceral way than i had
originally
and so what i would tell you is my
season of disconnection was one of the
was incr was super important there's
years they tell you don't plant your
fields so that that soil can
like
become really rich so that when seeds do
get planted they grow deep
okay
and
let me tell you this if you're not
honest with your community
they're not your community you don't
have community because you're lying to
them
and so living
in authentically just so you can be
around people
is inauthentic right it's it
you become that guy
i feel like that's been been me living
inauthentically for
for the last couple years yeah
it's exhausting brother struggle yeah so
let me tell you some bananas about brain
science your brain knows you are not
connected
and your brain knows you're lonely even
when you're surrounded by people
yeah and so
don't put yourself in a situation where
you are with people that you are lying
to or hiding from or pretending with
because your brain's gonna start
sounding the alarms you're not safe here
you're not safe here you're not safe
here
it's much better to be authentic and i
love that you've already had some of
these conversations and it's often faith
crisis faith conversations or did we
really believe that when we were kids
versus this and why right most of the
time
you're shocked by how many people around
you
think that way
nobody just has said it yet and when one
person says it everyone's like oh thank
god yeah that's crazy you know what i
mean and then
and then there's people on a spectrum
who are great people they're great
people of character they great morals
and they don't they don't believe any of
it anymore it's just now i'm out and
there's those that actually get more
entrenched more conservative over time
and they're still my friends too right
i think what you've got to do is make
peace with what you actually believe
have you spent a minute writing down
here's what i believe right now
you know i've i've actually started that
i've been listening to your shows for
quite a while and
i've been writing my wife letters
um awesome
and that's been that's cool did she
write you back just getting it under my
brain yeah
she i'm better at writing and she's
better at uh talking it through so cool
awesome yeah it's been it's been good
well that's that's phenomenal
so let me leave you with this okay
okay
i hope that my values
never change
i hope that my values where i treat
people with dignity respect i'm a person
of curiosity
i'm a person of character
i've got several core values
i'm a person who believes in god i have
core values
i hope those never change
i hope my beliefs change
radically throughout my life
because then if not why listen to a
podcast why listen why read books why
hang out with other people
why
because the reason we do that is to
learn new things i believed when i was a
kid that plants just grew and then i
learned about chlorophyll and borophil
i learned my beliefs about how plants
grow changed
i want that to be the same in my faith i
want that to be the same in parenting
and it's when we can go oh my gosh i did
xyz for all these years and then
i learned i was hurting people i got to
stop
right and we grieve it then we go on to
the next thing
so i want you to hold your beliefs
loosely and begin to dig in on yourself
be curious with yourself not judgmental
and here's the
go ahead
i was just going to say i think it's
it's taking me a little while to accept
um that asking questions
is okay yeah now you're on to it
that's one of my core values is i will
always ask questions
and if i find myself in a institution or
an enterprise that says no questions are
able to be asked here
and by the way behind closed doors i
work for dave ramsey i've asked him
questions about debt and he's answered
them and i said yeah but what about this
and come on man like just just you and
me dude we're hanging out by ourselves
what about this and he's talked to
i'm in a culture where i can ask
questions
because that's one of my values
belief answers we may come out to
different answers but the beliefs and i
i do agree with dave on that stuff but
the beliefs man i want those to be all
over the place you do have permission
asked questions in any place that tells
you you don't have permission
is a is a is a place that's hiding
something
it's okay to ask questions that's a
cornerstone of wisdom right that's a
cornerstone of searching
faith is not knowing everything and the
opposite was it and lamont the opposite
of faith is not doubt the office
opposite of faith is certainty
i'll say that again the opposite of
faith is not doubt the opposite of faith
is certainty
and so man
going through life certain is a scary
proposition
going through life holding it loosely
and saying wow what's next while
tethered to your values tethered deeply
to those values
really really important
find a mentor that you can talk to
someone who's five years 10 years 20
years down the road they actually have
deconstruction coaches a friend of mine
justin mcroberts folks like that who
will walk alongside you and help you
think through some of these things
what's the good parts of my faith what's
the what's the parts that i need to let
sit down i need to move on where else
can i go what's what do the values look
like when they're untethered a little
bit um people like justin mcgraw folks
who are actual coaches just like a
therapist but they walk alongside you
they're incredible
i recommend you grab somebody like that
and help you walk through this season
your kids are lucky to have you
continue to be a person of character
continue to be honest continue to ask
good questions and continue to show up
show up show up thank you so much sean